E3 2023 is dead but why was the big
event canceled the esa president and CEO
Stanley pierre-luis spoke with
gamesindustry.biz and said quote we were
off to a strong start it was interest
among exhibitors industry players media
and certainly fans ultimately however
there were challenges that proved too
large to surmount as for what those
challenges were Pierre Louis continued
by saying quote First several companies
have reported that the timeline for
their game development have been altered
since the start of the covet pandemic
second economic headwinds have caused
several companies to reassess how they
invest in large marketing events and
third companies are starting to
experiment with how to find the right
balance between in-person events and
digital marketing opportunities in a
statement to Gamespot readpop also
confirmed that digital showcases
scheduled around E3 will still take
place those include summer game Fest and
Xbox and Bethesda showcases a company
also said that it will continue to work
with the essay on future E3 events
suggesting that though E3 2023 is
canceled this is not the end of the
iconic industry event readpop and the
esa announced the cancellation of e3
2023 after months of uncertainty
surrounding the event big Publishers
like Sony Microsoft and Nintendo said
they'd skip the event and just recently
Ubisoft also said it was pulling out in
favor of holding its own Ubisoft forward
showcase and speaking of that showcase
could it finally be the event where we
see more of ub's Avatar frontiers of
Pandora maybe however if you hate
waiting then you might be excited to
hear details for the game have allegedly
leaked online now keep in mind these
details have not been confirmed and
although they seem to have been taken
from the game's product sheet you should
take them as rumor not fact according to
script leaks R6 the game will center
around a navi child who has been
abducted by the RDA and trained to work
for them in the game it seems your goal
is to reconnect with your heritage and
protect Pandora instead these alleged
details go on to mention character
customization crafting gear skill
upgrades weapons like Bose Spears ARs
and shotguns as well as aerial combat
and more what's your excitement level
for frontiers of Pandora do you think
it's going to be a hit or will it suffer
like the game for its Disney sibling
Marvel's Avengers a game that is getting
its final update today possibly the
biggest change in update 2.8 is the way
the marketplace functions now the
marketplace has been unlocked meaning
almost all outfits emotes takedowns and
nameplates are available to all players
items earned through the campaign
progression and via the Cosmetic vendor
must still be obtained as normal
shipments and hero challenge cards have
been removed entirely with update 2.8
and anything unlocked through these
methods is now automatically given to
players as Marketplace items those who
earn a trophy or achievement for April
1st will be grand the founders gift
which contains Iron Man's variable
threat response battle suit this is
Crystal Dynamics way of thanking the
players for checking out Marvel's
Avengers hit the comment section and let
me know if you're sad about the
cancellation of e3 and or the looming
shutdown of Marvel's Avengers
foreign